Look there's a bird!
Every time.
Look there's a dog!
There's no dog.
What?!
Hey..
I told you there was a dog!
Come on, higher lobs!
Good luck!
Are you okay?
Hey Emil!
How's it going?
Hey!
Ready to play?
First I gotta tell you this one story that happened
to me on the way here.
Can you imagine that a squirrel with a football in it's mouth.
What if they just come from practice?
Glacial fields of Iceland...
And if you add a bit of black pepper
it just really finishes of the breakfast.
It's one of the...
It's still warm the water you can like bathe in it.
Really good stuff!
Oh by the way, I was playing a tournament in Sicily last year.
Thing they do between all the points,
I thought it was quite interesting.
Miikka...
So what Antonio did,
he looked the opponent in the eye as he was doing a circular motion.
I think it could help your game if you stopped talking.
I mean...
Could you pass me the ball over there?
You got this.
I got it!
Ah thanks.
Ah don't worry I'll get it.
No I got it I got it I got it.
Here you go.
Uhm thank you.
So there is still 76% of you watching who haven't subscrided
so help us get to three million and do it now!
Until next time!